la foule entonne l'hymne national du
pays pour accueillir leurs soeurs leur
mère enfin on réconforte les enfants
avec des peluches la mère de l'ena après
des semaines d'angoissé arrive enfin une
étreinte rempli d'espoir des larmes
coulent une paix s'installe
cette jeune ukrainienne est fébrile à
l'idée de commencer sa nouvelle vie
et des armes dont
plusieurs ressortissants seront hébergés
par des familles d'accueil
mariani crois toujours pas après toute
cette attente anastasia et sa fille sont
enfin au québec pour rassurer ces
nouveaux arrivants le ministre boulet a
tenu à les rencontrer c'est important
pour moi de leur dire bienvenue au nom
des québécois et de leur faire
comprendre qu'on allait s'occuper d'eux
indépendamment de la nature de leurs
besoins
c'est le deuxième vol nolisé organisé
par ottawa d'une série de trois plus de
120 milles ukrainiens ont été acceptés
au programme d'autorisation de voyage
d'urgence canada ukraine mais seulement
35 mille sont arrivés au canada
c'est ce qu' on doit faire mieux en même
temps on fait déjà beaucoup
les familles quittent l'aéroport vers
leur prochain défi créer leur nouvelle
vie comme natalia arrivée au pays il ya
trois semaines de nouveaux meubles pour
une nouvelle vie toute une expérience
pour charlotte qui l'accueille et pas
juste comme ils viennent qui sont en
vacances ses comparses avec eux à
travers une étape importante de leur vie
qui ça touche à notre intimité alala
avoir de la bienveillance et respecter
les limites de tous ajoute t'elle
intéressant de penser de combien de
temps est-ce qu'on veut accueillir dans
quelles conditions on aimerait
accueillir comment on aimerait aider
natalia est reconnaissante tech qui
cette famille a pris soin de nous
charlotte est une femme formidable dit
elle une expérience qui restera gravée
dans la mémoire des enfants comme une
leçon de générosité
ici marie josée paquet comme radio
canada montréal